Hi I'm Gabrielle, and I'm going to be
your instructor for UIKit Fundamentals.
If you're taking this course, you should
have built at least one single view app
that adheres to the NBC design pattern,
which means, you know how to add objects
and storyboard and connect them in your
view controller and you're familiar with
some basic features of UIKit,
the iOS user interface library.
If you're not familiar
with these concepts,
we recommend you take Intro to
iOS Development with Swift first.
A link to that course is
in the instructor's notes.
This course is all about becoming
more comfortable with UIKit and
mastering its most
widely used components.
Our primary goal is to give you lots
of opportunities for hands-on coding.
And you'll build lots of small apps
to help you learn specific concepts.
At the end of the course, you'll have
the skills required to build a mean
generating app from the bottom up.
Let's take a detailed look at
this app in the next video.